[Applause]
welcome to the
inaugural Gutfeld town hall tonight
we're joined by an audience from the
Eastern State Correctional
Facility great great Greg Greg Greg Greg
Greg as well as a uh youth groups from
around the
worldes
a I'll be home soon and of course my old
roommate Steve the creepy
magician
yeah take that special report now
tonight's guest has many notable moments
on the campaign Trail specifically how
he's dealt with the media take a look do
you condemn white supremacy and white
nationalism I mean what this kind who
are you with it's Washington Post all
right so potato potato okay look at me
of course I condemn any form of vicious
racial discrimination in this country
you didn't say that you condemn white
supremacy though I'm not I'm not going
to recite some catechism for you I'm
against vicious racial discrimination in
this country so I'm not pledging
allegiance to your new religion of
modern wokeism which absolutely Feats
fits the test I'm not going to bend the
need of religion I'm sorry but do I
condemn vicious racial discrimination
yes I do am I going to play your silly
game of gotcha no I'm not yeah well
played well
played please welcome back to the show
GOP Presidential candidate VI Ras
[Music]
[Applause]
Swami all
right they we got some questions for you
from viewers all over the world the
first one's from Tony what is the most
important problem that you'd fix
and how will you do
it shut down the Deep State the people
who we elect to run the government
should once again be the ones who
actually run the government I don't
think that's too much to ask but it's
not the way things work in the United
States of America today so as soon as I
get in there and I've been a CEO I know
if somebody works for you and you can't
fire them that means they don't work for
you yeah I'm going to fire 75% of the
federal bureaucrats I'm going to
actually shut down government agencies
that shouldn't exist 8-year term limits
for all of the bureaucrats zerob based
budgeting that's how you actually drain
the swamp that's how you gut the Deep
State and if there's one war that I wage
it's not going to be some pointless
foreign war it's going to be the war on
our own shadow government and I'm going
to win so that's how I'm going to lead
the country
so how do you I mean can can you
actually fire all those people is that a
thing a president can do I didn't look
it up but can you actually do that
yeah you actually can Greg now they told
Donald Trump for all kinds of reasons
that he couldn't they duped him as I see
it they told them there are civil
service protections that stop you from
firing bureaucrats you got to do this
thing called reading the law though mhm
those Civil Service protections only
protect against individual employee
firings they do not apply to mass
layoffs and mass firings are absolutely
what I am bringing to the DC bureaucracy
I do not believe in incremental reform
it doesn't work I believe in actually
shutting it down and that's how we're
going to get the country back so that
means I could actually fire my whole
staff but I but if I just want to fire
one person like I don't know and then
I'd have to fire them all okay all right
chicken lizard I don't know if that's a
real name makes sense it actually makes
sense yeah it does okay uh he had this
guy chicken lizard I can't believe I'm
saying that asks if elected what would
your first Executive Order be once in
office
and would it be on day
one I do have a lot of executive orders
lined up for day one which are mostly
resending past unconstitutional
executive orders I'll give you an
example of one of them it's Executive
Order 11246 is what it's called Lynden
Johnson adopted it and it basically says
if you're getting Federal money or if
you're doing business with the federal
government you have to adopt toxic
racial and gender quota systems in your
ranks I would eliminate that I think
should get jobs based on Merit in this
country that's part of how we get this
toxic new form of Reverse Racism in
America end it the best way to stop
discrimination on the basis of the race
is stop discriminating on the basis of
race so it's not that complicated I've
pushed prior Republican presidents and
administrations on why they didn't do it
they said it's a political hill we
didn't want to die on well I'm not
afraid of dying on political Hills
actually that's how we win at the top of
those political Hills is by standing for
principles and so that's an example of
one of many past executive orders that
we're going to resend one by one and I
think it's going to take a president who
knows what he's doing to actually
navigate that that was exactly the one I
thought he would pick the one from
Lindon Johnson it's in my notes he had
it in his notes I add it in my notes
Dane Peterson asked a pretty good
question this is this is uh to me I feel
this as he does uh you've LED Donald
Trump's presidency but you've also said
you're the better choice because moving
the country forward requires fresh legs
what do you mean by that and how does
how does it uh differ from what Trump is
offering it's a good question because
it's it it it's like what what can you
do that Trump
can't sure so I'll give you an answer to
that but there's a deeper thing going on
right now that we need to talk about
what I can drew the Trump can't is two
things one is I have a deeper
understanding of the Constitution so I'm
not going to be duped when I shut down
agencies and fire a large number of
bureaucrats when I use our military on
our Southern border not just build the
wall when I actually end Birthright
citizenship for the kids of illegals to
whom it doesn't reply apply the swamp
gave Trump all kinds of reasons why he
couldn't do these things I understand
the current Supreme Court agrees with me
6 to3 and so I'm just going to do them
anyway and if they're going to sue me
that's fine I'm okay going to the
Supreme Court because we're going to win
so I think that's part of where I'm
different than Trump and I do think I
can reach the next generation and
reunite this country and dare I say
Inspire the next generation partly
because I am from the Next Generation
and so that's what I mean by fresh legs
gotcha but Greg I think there's
something deeper going on right now this
is important though we're about to fall
for a trick I think this system wants to
effectively narrow this field down to a
two- horse race between Donald Trump and
a puppet who they can control then to
eliminate Donald Trump from contention
and trot in their puppet to the White
House I think that's the game hiding in
plain sight and staring Us in the face
and I think we cannot fall into that
trap if you think this system is going
to even let Donald Trump get anywhere
near that white house I want the people
of this country to open their eyes and
once you see it you cannot unsee it and
so yes I like the man because he got
this fight started but I view it as our
job and my responsibility now to
actually finish it and I'm not going to
fall into the Trap that they've laid for
us do you think it's going to be uh uh
what they're trying to do is create a
DeSantis Haley or Haley DeSantis ticket
is that what's being worked behind the
scenes you
think I think it's not unlikely I think
the reality is Chris Christie dropping
out was a little bit of a footnote but
they're narrowing the field and I do
think that Nikki Haley is a candidate
that the mainstream media combined with
much of the Republican establishment the
donor class has chosen to prop up I
initially thought it might be Gavin
Newsome or Joe Biden but actually this
does a good favor for the permanent
state to do it within the Republican
Party itself so they can claim
nonpartisanship but still somebody who
is a reliable vessel for advancing their
agenda so they're voting for a two-horse
race between Nikki and Trump eliminate
Trump Trot in their puppet who they can
control and I'm in this to the very end
to make sure that doesn't happen because
our America First agenda cannot end with
Donald Trump it didn't start in 2016 it
started in
1776 and I'm in this to take this
another 250 years forward all right we
got to move on they so we're going to
see you tomorrow we're going to back for
part two of our town hall control
yourselves
people see you tomorrow up next lefties
hit a new level calling Trump the devil
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else